you are taking a live look at the Las
Vegas Pride night Parade route from our
Strat tower cam looking way from above
and we have our crew on the ground as
well our very own Ted florendo is there
as well a big part of it tonight Ted
thanks for bringing it in terms of live
coverage as well as a great forecast for
the weekend
it's great down here weather is
fantastic of course and everybody is
looking forward to this parade expected
to begin at seven o'clock a lot of
people are here lining the streets
already this shows you how popular this
parade is and how much support it gets
every year joining us live now is Jim
McMichael you're Jimmy I've known you
you came to my wedding I'm calling you
Jimmy but Michael will help me CVA joins
us live now uh you're not part of the
committee here but you help promote this
thing and as a big part of this every
year right absolutely but first of all
we got to get Unity
there we go I was going to ask when you
were going to bring it adds a little bit
of color I need I needed it I was gonna
I was waiting for you I know you're
gonna bring this I needed to be here
actually no actually the lbcva has
worked with Las Vegas Pride to help grow
this as a big event for the city we're
really unique because this event takes
place at night most of the pride parades
are in the morning on a Saturday or
Sunday but it's a Friday night it's a
great way for people to kick off their
weekend and enjoy all the pride
festivities that we've got planned from
tonight all the way through Sunday we
were just talking about you helped out
with so many Pride festivities around
the nation and other cities how's this
one Fair compared to the other one well
like I said this is a nighttime parade
there's only one other city that has a
nighttime parade and we're not typically
in June June is typically associated
with pride month but every city kind of
has their own spin June here do a parade
in June kind of not the best weather so
you know you know what the weather's all
about so here in October it's a great
time of weather a great time of year and
it's perfect weather for us